i did stand up for the second time at
whitney cummings house
whitney cummings uh had a stand-up
comedy show
in her driveway or her basketball court
really her driveway area and uh
it was a lot of fun you know the you
know whitney knows all these uh
influencers like these instagram
is the proper term hoes probably not
i'm kidding ladies but these instagram
and
well the teats are out i mean
they're not influencing people to go to
school
they're not doing a lot of adult
literacy programs from my understanding
i'm sure they have many philanthropic
endeavors
but you know a lot of it is the teats
are out and
uh and they all have like deals you know
they're hawking body oil
for millions and millions of dollars
on nj it's not my demo really
i like a working class philly from a
working class family from outside of
philly
i like a working class family from
outside of philly that begrudgingly has
to sit in a car together for 25 minutes
everyone's smoking cigarettes including
the dog
on the way to the show angry people
people that feel like they've been
slighted my audience is people that feel
like they've been
slighted like me because both of my
parents survived 9 11.
that's who my audience is so when i look
at these
hot instagram black lives matter
and you know all of these politically
correct
teats in the front row
um i i was like will i do well i don't
know but spade was there and whitney was
there and
the booker the comedy store was there
and some people were bombing by the way
you never really want to bomb when you
have people that you respect there but
some people just i mean
wow uh but most people doing great annie
letterman
murdered killed it very funny but
annie's like that she can kind of
[ __ ] bob and weave and really
you know when you're in a weird me and
annie came up in new york when we're in
a lot of weird situations
and you had to lend give yourself
over to that as a comedian and just go
we're in this [ __ ] up situation we're
going to call it out
and then a lot of other comedians get up
there and they're like
that that that day that
day have have you ever
been to have you ever
and the crowd's like hey we're instagram
influencers we think with our tits
what are you doing here can you [ __ ]
talk to us
can you [ __ ] i don't know who these p
olivia mun i don't even know who these
people are kesha
who what's that what's a ketchup
i don't even know what that is is that
like shakshouka
is that a dish who is this kesha
she said hello she because i'm kesha
like i'm gonna turn around i'm a huge
fan
she said that to me i had a peach in my
hand and i go do you think this is ripe
i was hitting it on the counter
[Music]
she's a singer apparently she did that
song tick-tock
tick-tock that was the song of every fat
freckled irish beast woman
who will still put it on facebook and be
like remember fridays and college at
suny new paltz that's my girls
tech talk you know it was every fat
slobs theme song who was trying to get a
[ __ ] in their ass at 3 a.m
at a suny school in new york freckled
irish beast women would listen to that
song that is what you've inspired kesha
yes or yes
that is what you have done that is what
you're me yes you want hot people
dancing to your music but it ain't
that's not the case
you know who loves that song me and a
wig
me and a wig and they'll still put it up
on facebook
and they go hey this was a song from me
and my girls
remember girls and they tag all the
other [ __ ]
hot air balloons that they went to a
suny school with
these [ __ ] boats that they went to
school with
i'm tagging all my girls and then you
just you just
you click on the the women that they've
tagged and it's just someone whose face
is like
you know the fat woman instagram shot
i've done it many times it's from up
here
up here tilted head that's fat woman
instagram up here tilted head you don't
know what's going on beneath my head
i bet it's hot though i bet it's a
cauldron a [ __ ] juice
that's what she did tucker there's a
place downtown
tick tock tick tock that's your heart
ladies
kesha and then miranda cosgrove who's on
icarly i don't i'm in a pedophile what
is this
i don't watch these things nickelodeon
drake and josh what are we nuts where
are the adults
where's candace owens
where is the exhumed corpse of william f
buckley i want to perform
what is icon did you watch this horse
[ __ ] when you were growing up you did
didn't you
rugrats yeah i car
i didn't have cable i didn't have cable
i come from the mean streets
my parents survived 911. i didn't get
the good [ __ ]
i didn't get the jedi patel movies in
the cable
my parents didn't have their skin
[ __ ] melted
i like pizza i don't know pete at all
i'm not i'm obviously i'm not throwing
any shade of pete
i know it's sad to have your dad killed
in 9 11.
but let's be very honest it's not worked
out horribly for him and this is the
fact so i'm willing to kill my parents
but this is what and kesha seemed like a
lovely woman
i they they all were lovely women i'm
none of this i just this world is not i
don't understand this world
what is icarly about
oh man it was a spin-off of drake and
josh and she lived in an apartment and
she had a
friend and a brother and they just got
into weird [ __ ] at school that was kind
of it
dude nickelodeon sucked the only good
things were doug
and doria they were [ __ ] good
they were [ __ ] good rugrats
fine i would go to my friends houses
they had cable they had nickelodeon we
didn't have cable
when i was a kid i watched melrose place
i watched
sydney and michael carry on alert affair
and michael had a beach house in malibu
and then sydney blew up the whole
apartment complex
and i learned words like blackmail and
abortion
so i'm sorry i wasn't watching cartoon
children
you [ __ ] [ __ ] shout out to aaron
spelling and darren starr
melrose place is [ __ ] iconic shout
out to heather lockyer i hope you're
okay wherever you are
you're probably parked on an off-ramp
somewhere but anyway i hope you're good
well she's had issues is what i'm saying
i don't know
she has she's probably parked somewhere
on an off ramp
trying to figure out where she is well
we're with you in spirit heather
[ __ ] these kids i watched beverly hills
90210 and nypd blue
great shows dennis franz that fat racist
what a genius what an actor
i like and they all have this attitude
you hit these hot instagram people this
attitude they're like
until they talk like hey hi
hi hi hi
hi
i had to leave amanda cerny who i don't
know has got like a trillion followers
she's got 25 million followers went up
and start re
starts reading whitney's act out of a
book
and i said and and it's just sweet girl
you know i'm not
[ __ ] on anybody here but i said that
was my time i looked at tom pop i said i
think it's time to go
tom papa brought a loaf of bread which i
just ate with my bare hands
in uh whitney's kitchen whitney's uh
whitney got some great pizza from big
mama's pizza
and i'd never had that and it was just
kind of like i don't know it's pretty
good
big mama and papa's pizza yeah it's
pretty good man she got cheese sticks
mozzarella sticks you don't find a lot
of mozzarella sticks in la
but when you got them and what's great
is i got to have pretty much all of the
food
because they don't eat the instagram
influencers don't eat
okay they don't eat they don't eat food
it's not allowed they take a picture
with an avocado once a month
and that's all the protein they need
so i was eating i was filling up but of
course some of the female comics are
filling up too you know they're not
exactly small
but it was a lot of fun it was an
interesting uh it was an interesting
time
kesha didn't show up sadly but she was
there the other day yeah
i kid cash what do i know she's you know
so fun she seems like such a mature
like almost dark
brooding type of person but then the
music is like
it's like an alarm clock or songs right
it's kind of like an alarm clock but
they're good but it's like a fun alarm
clock it's like
i'm i'm waking up tick-tock tip my life
means something
that's what her music is it's just fat
women in state schools going
making the memories someone kidnap me
please
they want to get kidnapped those women
someone take me away
someone bury me under a lake show me
that i'm special
[Laughter]
but i did well i had fun in the middle
of my set i said oh good crystal i just
got here
i said he'll go next that didn't get a
big
chuckle that was a ve that was not a
warmly received joke
there was a little chill in the air but
it was a good
thing whitney really loves stand-up
comedy and i think all these other women
really like her because whitney's
you know real deal comic kind of in that
boys club of being able to really throw
down
really written whitney writes her ass
off you know what i mean
um um and she just [ __ ] really does
well and her new jokes are very funny
you know what i mean
but then when she's like all right now
we're gonna have the instagram
influencers come up and do my material
and they're like
kids don't get injured anymore
have you heard that and the witness has
to explain to them she's like
well there's the premise comes first
honey the premise comes first and then
the punch line
don't no no no no no don't snort the
microphone we talk into it
no we talk into it
um but i was uh i was really glad that i
was included now and now i'm sure i
won't be again
but content is king if i've learned one
thing its content
is king but it was very nice and she got
a lot of pizza i didn't even know
whitney knew what food
was because every time on there she was
always trying to give me like
plant-based
popsicles she's like this is a chocolate
kale pop
i'm like what she's like how about some
raspberry dust
i'm like wait what she never has regular
butter
she always has some weird butter she's
like this is butter from a cactuses
[ __ ]
and i'm like well how about how about a
cow
how about a cow's butter i didn't even
know she knew what [ __ ] dude if you had
said to me
whitney's having a comedy show and she's
getting food i would have
never thought that we were gonna be
[ __ ] doing pizza
cheese sticks garlic bread
how [ __ ] cool was that how unexpected
was that
i thought we're gonna be all eating like
you know like taking one bite of a leaf
and then handing it to the next person
to bite it you know